tu es noir tu es une femme donc très
fragile je t'ai méfiante est-ce que vous
aussi vous avez vu ces mêmes a priori en
nous regardant la première fois est ce
que vous avez eu les mêmes préjugés
qu'on a eu l'un envers l'autre
on a souvent tendance à s'attacher à ce
qui nous diffère différence est entre
nous les gens plutôt que ce qui nous
rapproche
je suis d'origine portugaise j'ai
immigré en suisse lorsque je t'avais
huit ans avec ma maman elle voulait me
donner une meilleur moyen de vie amère
moi je suis originaire d'angola
ma mère a émigré en suisse lorsque
j'avais 3 ans elle a quitté son pays
d'origine pour pouvoir me donner les
meilleures opportunités possibles dans
ma vie pour avoir ce que parce qu' elle
n'a pas eu donc un une chance pour moi
de pouvoir suivre des études beaucoup de
pression de la part de mes parents ma
mère mon père mes frères il voulait
absolument que je deviens quelqu'un
d'important que je devienne avocate
doctoresse fallait absolument que je
vienne quelqu'un je n'avais pas droit à
l'erreur et l'idée que je devienne la
matrice ou une danseuse ou juste artiste
était pas envisageable pour eux c'était
leur plus grande peur
moi j'ai également eu beaucoup de
pressions de la part de ma famille aux
yeux de tous les sacrifices qu'ils ont
faits pour que je puisse être ici devant
vous il fallait absolument pour mes
parents que j'obtienne un diplôme pas
n'importe lequel je pouvais pas me
permettre d'être caissier ou des choses
comme ça alors cédé beau métier mais ce
n'était pas suffisant pour eux aux yeux
des sacrifices qu'ils ont faits et en
plus de ça j'avais la pression étant
donné que j'étais le seul enfant noir de
ma région
rien n'allait très très peu et j'ai dû
vivre avec ça libre si je peux dire le
jour où ma maman est tombé en dépression
ça a beaucoup ça m'a beaucoup affecté
tous les jours je prenais soin d'elle et
tous les jours je devais trouver un
moyen pour sortir tout cette peine que
j'avais à l'intérieur de moi parce que
ça me si je peux dire me bouffer de la
voir comme ça et c'était la danse
c'était le seul moyen et du jour au
lendemain ils sont partis définitivement
au portugal et je me suis retrouvé livré
à moi-même et à ce moment là je me suis
dit mais sois toi même mot fuck fais ce
que tu as envie d'être ce que tu as
envie de faire et écoute pas les autres
et n'ai pas peur surtout des autres je
me suis senti libre au moment où j j'ai
obtenu mon mon diplôme j'ai fait des
études en tant que dessinateur dans le
bâtiment c'était plus pour ma mère que
pour moi mais à ce moment là je me suis
sentie libérée de la pression qui peut
avoir vis-à-vis de ma vie à moi parce
que j'avais l'impression d'avoir payé ma
dette par rapport aux sacrifices que mes
parents avaient fait pour moi et dès
lors j'ai commencer à m'écouter mois et
que moi
ça n'avait plus d'importance les
attentes que mes parents avaient parce
que avoir un diplôme ce n'était pas
suffisant pour eux ils voulaient plus
plus plus plus et en fait à ce moment là
j'ai dit stop et j'ai décidé de
m'écouter donc je me suis lancé dans la
danse sap a été femme étant donné que
pour beaucoup c'est pas vraiment un
métier étant donné qu'en suisse on a
très très peu d'opportunités et s'était
constamment des c'est pas un métier
comment tu vas te nourrir et en fait ça
ça m'importait peu parce que ça me
faisait du bien en fait ça me faisait un
bien fou et je me sentais moi même
j'avais l'impression que je mûrissais
jours après deux jours et chaque matin
j'étais ravie de me lever même si je
savais que j'avais peut-être pas payer
toutes mes factures pour remplir mon
frigo mais j'étais heureux parce que je
faisais ce que j'avais envie de faire
et est-ce que vous tous tu as quand vous
écoutez vous même est ce que vous êtes
heureux le matin quand vous vous levez
est ce que vous avez peur des gens qui
vous entourent de vos proches
enfin d'être vous même vous avez le
sentiment d'être là où devait être est
ce que vous avez le sentiment de vivre
votre vie pas la subir nous aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on la vie et sur ton sens
libre parler c'est vraiment pas notre
truc et et d'ailleurs on va arrêter on
va se libérer de ces micro au site
[Musique]
avi
wakanim affine ça avait
dieu
[Musique]
m
du
[Musique]
comme prévu
à moins que
[Musique]
il fallait à mon job
awa thiam
oui
c'est là
jean de la
à
non
[Musique]
m
on avait un
[Musique]
e
labeaume
[Musique]
jean k
à
la plainte
tiens
oui
[Musique]
à
e
hello
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]